the landmark four-day sex abuse summit
at the Vatican is now in its third day
the hierarchy of the Catholic Church has
been criticized by abuse victims and
their advocates for failing to punish
those who turned a blind eye to sex
abuse within the church but this
extraordinary meeting could be a major
turning point for the church and the
victims of sexual abuse Seth Doane is in
Rome with more on today's agenda Seth
good morning good morning earlier today
I had the opportunity to be in the room
where the summit is taking place as Pope
Francis gathered with bishops from
around the world the sexual abuse of
children and youth is in no small
measure due to the abuse of power in the
area of administration this morning
German Cardinal Reinhard Marx addressed
the importance of accurately reporting
abuse files that could have documented
the terrible deeds and named those
responsible were destroyed or not even
created instead of the perpetrators the
victims were regulated and silenced
imposed on them the Vatican says
developing protocols aimed at the
protection of minors could help other
vulnerable people including those
serving the church when you're being
heard sexually i says none it's really
impossible to speak on Doris Wagner was
just 24 when she was raped by a priest
in her convent she says her superior
blamed her and she could not imagine
going to police sounds like if I did
that I would attack the church in a you
know able to hurt the church but you
were being hurt you were being abused
but that was not important
combating that culture of silence has
been one of the topics of these meetings
but we found there significant distance
between rhetoric in the summit and
reality on the street in India right now
five nuns have rallied behind their
sister who alleges she was raped by her
bishop 13 times they say they tried to
contact church authorities and the
Vatican's ambassador but got no response
they won twice and I doesn't put this
aside sex abuse survivors held
yet another protest here in Rome today
hoping that their pain will spur these
bishops to take action for CBS this
morning Saturday
Seth Dome wrong the church has to keep
dealing with new chapters in this crisis
there is a lot to confront here still
deal with it they must yes so many
people hurt by this and as you said
we'll continue to see some of those